is the Occupy movement full of rapists
thieves and criminals
yes but more importantly racists firstly
sorry for the low-res technical
difficulties this week but we'll have it
fixed by next week I wanted to talk
about the fact that them I've had the
chance to see a lot of the Occupy
protests across the country and to be
honest I feel bad for a lot of these
people most of them are not very smart
and I think a lot of them are are
misfits or dropouts or addicts really
just looking for a place to belong so my
heart goes out to them and of course
Barack Obama has chosen to identify with
these people and I think that's because
when you're polling poorly with general
mainstream America you have to dancer
the one that brought you in this case
radical leftist socialists but the
people with whom I really have a problem
are the media and entertainment elite
who are trying to build up this movement
and these people into something they're
not as though they're the politically
aware social conscience of America as
opposed to the real morons that they are
now these aren't the same folks who
accused the Tea Party of being racist
and there yet there's another problem
you have what I call to get the n-word
out of the White House party the Tea
Party what what what's that what
underlines that screw the country we're
gonna do whatever we do to get this
black man weekend we're gonna do
whatever we can to get this black man re
please wait the same Tea Party whose
favorite candidate right now is Herman
Cain hey babe the truth we want to get
this round so we can get back in
this same media tries to romanticize the
Occupy movement much like I did with the
60s flowerpower delinquents so I'm using
the media logic here if the Tea Party is
racist because the person with whom they
disagree on policy is black then the
occupiers must all hate Jews come on Joe
wait these people really are racist
Yovani that's why you're fighting it to
expand and I think that the Zionist Jews
who are running these big banks and our
Federal Reserve which is not run by the
federal government they need to be run
out of this country you can't speak
English in Israeli I guess folks not
only have there been countless arrests
and calls to violence at the Occupy
protests but if you google occupy and
racism you will find dozens upon dozens
of racist or anti-semitic tirades and I
would encourage you to take those links
and post them to your Facebook your
Twitter your blog and hashtag it occupy
racism so that you can help
counterbalance the narrative that the
media has tried to set here once you do
let me know below and I'll do my best to
respond and who knows maybe the media
will stop throwing out racist
accusations toward the wrong people the
same people who want to elect a black
man to the presidency of the United
States the real black guy - not a
biracial guy who was raised by white
people but a full-on black dude and
Herman Cain is a is probably well liked
by some of the problems because it hides
the racist elements of the Republican
Party conserve them conservative
movement and Tea Party movement
all right so your honor a game I see you
occupiers and that goodtime gal Jeanine
who would have gotten away with it -
you're right we do hate all blacks Jews
and Mexicans Herman Cain he went in
there cause he's not a real black man
one day Ln the Basilica sees Val Kilmer
but everyone for your overt racism it
would be called on our covert Rayson
tina takatori world everything's down
everything down is up real racism is not
racism and racism is racism girl bomb
too